spotted that he's so tactically sharp  and instead of allowing any nasty checks  later he just brought his rook across  and now suddenly black is the one  threatening checkmate this is a  checkmate threat to the white king  and magnus spots it both sides spotting  the traps but we about to see a result  wow yes we do let's go back to the  players dave navarro smiling we'll show  this later but he spotted a winning idea  against the world champion  and look at that what a moment for him  yeah  that is a nice celebration by david  navarro winning against the world the  champion magnus of course logging off  but this is a big moment  for david navarro see that big smile oh  how  did you see earlier he had a flower yeah  there was a yellow flower and there was  a huge smile on his face  yellow and blue yep  what a nice celebration by david navarra  and i love seeing that  big smile on his face